as the legend goes 19 years ago this
month the freak bolt of lightning struck
the home of Joe Biden in Wilmington
Delaware the lightning hit a pond nearby
traveled through some wires and caused a
kitchen fire make matters worse Joe
Biden was not at home he was 100 miles
away being uh in Washington being
interviewed on Meet the Press now
fortunately or suspiciously depending on
how you look at it a future doctor named
Jill Biden was on the scene and she
called 9-1-1 firefighters quickly
arrived to find the blaze hadn't spread
past the kitchen within about 20 minutes
everything was fine we got it pretty
early the local fire chief said fire
department later called the fire
insignificant there were no casualties
in that respect and in every other
respect there is no comparison between
Joe Biden's kitchen fire from 2004 and
what has just unfolded on the island of
Maui over 100 people are confirmed that
after one of the worst wildfires in this
country's history roughly a thousand
people are missing and it's fear that
most of them could be children countless
homes and businesses have been destroyed
damages estimated in the billions and
yet on Monday the president of the
United States somehow managed to compare
all of that devastation
to his kitchen fire two decades ago
touring Maui he didn't address the
bureaucratic ineptitude that led to so
many deaths he didn't explain why it
took him nearly two weeks to interrupt
his vacation to visit the people of Maui
instead he told residents of Maui The
Familiar story about that lightning
strike at his home this time adding even
more details that make absolutely no
sense watch
I don't want to
compare difficulties but we have a
little sense Jill and I
what it's like to lose a home
years ago now 15 years ago I was in
Washington do we Meet the Press
it was a sunny Sunday
and lightning struck at home
on a little Lake it's outside of our
home and I don't like a big pond
and hit a wire and came up underneath
our home
into the heating Ducks the air
conditioning duct make a long story
short
I almost lost my wife
my 67 Corvette
and my cat
put all kidding aside
I watched the firefighters
the way they responded
no there's no expression
I grew up right across the street from a
fire hall in Claymont Delaware
and the expression is God made man then
he made a few firefighters
I don't want to compare difficulties but
when I hear about a thousand people
dying in a fire I'm reminded of the time
that I stubbed my toe on the kitchen
counter
so to recap the timeline Joe Biden was
in Washington lightning struck his home
in Delaware via his pond and air
conditioning events somehow in the 20
minutes it took to extinguish the fire
Joe Biden raced home from Washington to
Delaware more than an hour away by train
just in time to see firefighters save
his wife from near certain death oh do
you also wants he also wants you to know
that he nearly lost his 67 Corvette in
the blaze a potential loss that he lists
alongside his cat and his wife
like Joe Biden's claims about you know
over performing in law school or trying
to free Nelson Mandela or seeing gay men
casually kissing on a street corner in
the 1950s this story is yet another lie
a fabrication but Joe Biden's
embellishment of his kitchen fire in
this context is on another level it may
in fact be the most insulting thing a
president of the United States has ever
said
really as parents scramble to find their
missing children Joe Biden wants
everyone in the room to know that he's a
victim too he almost lost his Corvette
after all
now as you might expect Joe Biden's
display of narcissism in Maui didn't
stop there in his quest to make the
unprecedented human suffering and Maui
about himself Joe Biden also talked
about the death of his son as he does at
every possible opportunity no point in
playing the clip it's the same thing you
said dozens of other times
the point here isn't to highlight what a
terrible person Joe Biden is anyone
who's been paying attention at any point
in his political career understands that
well I mean we were told that decency
was on the ballot when he ran for
president but it turns out that Joe
Biden is perhaps the least decent man to
ever hold the office which is really
saying something
what's interesting is the lack of
outrage in response to what Joe Biden is
doing
somehow neither party is calling for Joe
Biden's impeachment over his handling of
the disaster in Maui no rap stars have
derailed any disaster relief telethons
by claiming that Joe Biden doesn't care
about Hawaiian people
now for anyone who was alive in 2005
this is all rather startling
remember when they they ripped George W
bush apart for flying over New Orleans
on on Air Force One after Hurricane
Katrina that was that was a mortal sin
at the time
he took Air Force One over the city to
survey the damage rather than landing
and causing a commotion on the ground
the idea was that bush didn't want to
distract from Su efforts it also would
have been rather impractical and
probably unsafe for the president United
States to repel down into a flood zone
but even 10 years later I mean they're
still complaining about it
or or rather 10 years after this they
were complaining here's Face the Nation
on the 10-year anniversary and this was
seven years ago uh still talking about
what a disaster this was for George Bush
watch
from the 10-year anniversary of
Hurricane Katrina we're joined from the
heart of New Orleans by historian
Douglas Brinkley the author of The Great
Deluge about the disaster Mr Brinkley I
want to start with help us understand
sort of
help us apportion the blame for the
disaster of Hurricane Katrina who was at
fault and how much were they at fault
well George W bush did a terrible
leadership job during that crisis he
kind of acted like nothing was happening
wrong for the first days he had been in
San Diego where he played air guitar and
then he did the famous flyover being
very detached from the devastation and
that that photograph that damaged his
presidency immensely of him just peering
down at the abyss
yes he's just peering down at the abyss
flying over the devastation after
Hurricane Katrina was a scandal a
defining moment of the Bush presidency
it made bush look detached according to
uh this historian that faced the nation
was interviewing now the flyover they're
complaining about took place on August
31st of 2005
and for those who know their history
that's two days after Katrina made
landfall in Louisiana two days later
48 hours later he was surveying the
damage
now for comparison this was Joe Biden
nearly a week after the fires in Maui
began watch
will you come talk about the Hawaii
response Mr President
no comment Joe Biden says as he gets
back to his vacation while children burn
in Maui
if only George Bush had tried that
tactic he should have just said no
comment while on vacation then he'd be
fine makes perfect sense now of course
if George Bush had said no comments
after he was asked about the people who
died in Hurricane Katrina it would have
been a political Scandal that rocked the
nation and dominated news coverage for
six months people would still be talking
about Michael Moore would have done a
whole documentary on it
it would be considered one of the most
infamous moments in the history of the
American presidency
now Joe Biden's no comment on the other
hand did not attract
quite that level of outrage or really
any outrage at all at least not from the
from the Press
the simple explanation for why the media
is excusing what Joe Biden is doing or
isn't doing is that he's a Democrat and
also Democrats run Hawaii Bush on the
other hand is a republican so he doesn't
he doesn't get the benefit of the doubt
in Maui there's no conceivable angle in
which Republicans can be responsible
now there really wasn't any angle in New
Orleans either
given that the city is run by democrats
but they found a way
yet they can't find a way with this
story so they simply like it to they
wanted to just go away as quickly as
possible
the more officials in Hawaii open their
mouths the more believable uh this
theory is watch as Maui County mayor
Richard Bisson refuses to say how many
children are missing and then threatens
to end the press conference when a
reporter presses him on it watch
I don't know yes you do
how many children are missing
you know I knew the answer to that I
would be happy to answer that you have
no estimate as to how many children are
missing in this right now
[Music]
oh I'm sorry
so rather than provide any estimate
whatsoever the mayor threatens to end
the press conference he starts fighting
with the reporter what that tells you is
that the estimates are dire
the governor of Hawaii Josh Green is
undoubtedly aware of that so like the
mayor of Maui County he's been dodging
questions when asked recently why the
sirens didn't sound on the island to
alert its residents that the fires were
happening the governor started talking
about climate change instead
we've been discussing there are now a
lot of questions about all of the
policies and procedures
um you know the National Weather Service
had issued a fire watch for your state
August 6th a few days before the fire
hit
with the siren system you said to CNN on
Monday and again on Tuesday that you
believe some of the sirens were broken
when did you learn they weren't fully
functional
we assess every siren across the state
on the first of the month and then we
asked people to update them and fix them
to their abilities
you know I of course I as a person as a
father as a doctor's
I wish all the sirens went off the
challenge that you've heard and it's not
to excuse or explain anything the
challenge has been that historically
those Sirens are used for tsunamis uh
that's when I came to Hawaii 23 years
ago was told when I was living down near
the shore
so Josh Green is saying that the problem
isn't really Josh green or Richard
Bisson or Joe Biden or even the electric
company it's not their fault that Maui's
burning
sure the sirens didn't go off but uh you
know the real problem is that you made
the world a tenth of a degree hotter if
you hadn't done that none of this would
be happening
that's the excuse we're hearing from the
media that's what we're hearing from the
Democrat Party this is all about climate
change
now you go down the list of officials in
the state and you'll find more and more
incompetence as you do take Mr Khalil
Manuel for example he's the deputy
director of the state's Commission on
Water Resource Management
on August 10th the West Maui land
company sent a letter to Khalil
complaining that his commission had held
up a request to free up more water to
fight all the fires according to the
land company they had tried to expedite
water diversion from streams to fight
the fires but in the letter the Land
Company complains that kaleo's Water
Commission had held up the request for
several hours on various technicalities
saying that they needed to consult a
local farmer first obtain permission
from the fire department all this red
tape
the delay could have cost people their
lives it's hard to say at this point uh
how many
it's also hard to say hard to know why
khalil's commission held up the water
request
is your cell phone in desperate need of
replacement you know the signs short
battery life so you have to have charger
on hand all the time crack screen that
gives you glass splinters it's time to
put that old phone to rest and upgrade
to a new 5G Samsung Galaxy for Pure Talk
uh for free get a free 5G Samsung Galaxy
with two day battery life edged Edge
display and Ultra strong Gorilla Glass
when you sign up for Pure talks
unlimited talk text and 15 gig data plan
for just 35 a month plus it comes with a
mobile hotspot get all the data you
could ever need for half the price of
the big carriers on America's Most
Dependable 5G Network go to puretalk.com
Walsh for your free super durable 5G
Samsung Galaxy when you switch to pure
talk again visit puretalk.com Walsh and
make the switch to my cell phone company
puretalk the official Wireless partner
of the daily wire you may have seen this
clip from a well before these wildfires
started it's making the rounds online I
want you to watch Kaleo this is that uh
government official talk about the
importance of equity and preserving
water watch
the commission is responsible for prior
authorizing statute to protect and
manage all water resources in the state
one water is like taking it and looking
at it from a holistic system perspective
and that's not any different than how
Hawaiians traditionally manage water you
know and in essence we treated at a
native Hawaiians treated water is one of
the Earthly manifestations of a God and
aqua Kane and so that reverence
um for a resource and that reciprocity
in relationship was was something that
was really really important to our world
view and and well-being right and living
in an island in isolated from other you
know civilizations
um and so I think where it shifted to
today or over time is that we've become
used to looking at water as like
something which we use and not
necessarily something that we Revere as
that thing that gives us life right I
mean to me it's a shift in value set
um and you know if we can start to
really look at how we as humans in an
island
um Can re-connect to that traditional
value set so really my model is always
like let water connect us and not divide
us like we we can share it but it
requires true conversations about equity
so that was the guy in charge of the
water as the island burned now does this
mean that Khalil withheld water from
firefighting efforts for the sake of
equity
seems possible
we do know that this man never should
have been in any position of authority
whatsoever
take a look at khalil's biography on the
Obama Foundation website and you'll find
lines like this quote he believes that
ancient wisdom and traditional
ecological knowledge of native peoples
will help save the world
in other words he's an unserious
politician and person he's the last
person you want to determine where water
goes in an emergency like when the fire
is headed towards your home you don't
want ancient wisdom you don't want
someone talking about the reciprocity of
our relationship with Mother Earth
you want basic competence and you want
water and lots of it
water that by the way you are going to
use and not Revere or have a
relationship with
as it happens unserious also describes
the Regulators in charge of monitoring
Hawaii electric which likely caused this
fire on a sub stack investigative
journalist Lee Fang reports that Hawaii
electric knew about the threat of
wildfire specifically in a regulatory
filing last summer Hawaiian Electric
disclosed that the quote risk of utility
system causing a wildfire ignition is
significant
the estimated the work to address that
risk would cost about six million
dollars
now the company ultimately spent 245
000 on minor upgrades to their
infrastructure that's hundreds of
thousands of dollars less than they
spend on lobbying in the past four years
and all that law being apparently paid
off Hawaii's Chief utility regulator
recently appeared in a puff Beast
documentary this year for Hawaii
electric and Regulators never forced the
company to make the more expensive
safety upgrades that they knew they
needed
it falls on substack journalists like
Lee Fang to report on all this because
right now the corporate media isn't
interested in any of it
instead like the governor of Hawaii
they're pinning these fires on climate
change
Vanity Fair just published a piece
entitled quote how bad how bad do things
have to get for Joe Biden to declare a
climate emergency
along the same lines the AP reported
that climate change fueled the Maui
fires
already the effort is underway to
absolve these bureaucrats of
responsibility it's likely that in the
end only the utility company will suffer
any consequences if any at all probably
in the form of a fine
that's what happened to the electric
company involved in the 2018 camp fire
in California which killed 85 people
government officials in that case made
several key errors including uh failing
to activate an emergency warning system
sounds familiar
but none of them paid any real price for
it
so what we're seeing it's more
complicated than a left-right partisan
split where Republicans take heat during
disasters and Democrats get a pass
that's part of it of course but the
reason Democrats are able to avoid any
accountability during catastrophes also
has a lot to do with one of the main
functions of a bureaucracy
why they exist in the first place which
is to defuse responsibility because when
everyone is responsible for disaster
nobody is
they can blame you for making the planet
hotter instead of emitting their own
failures
they can make up stories about kitchen
fires instead of doing anything
productive
18 years after Hurricane Katrina this
total failure of leadership
it's not enough to destroy a presidency
anymore or even damage a political party
this is what regression looks like
and it all but guarantees that as
horrible as this destruction is
we haven't seen the last disaster like
this one if you'd like to see what else
I have to say you can access my full
show by going to dailywire.com or by
going to the Matt Walsh Show Twitter
page hope to see you there Godspeed